Ihr hört CRE Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 207. Ausgabe von CRE nach einer viel zu langen Pause, für die ich mich eigentlich entschuldigen muss, aber irgendwie hat es im letzten Jahr alles nicht so richtig gepasst. Und es war auch mal so ein bisschen mein Anliegen, dieses Format auch nur dann fortzusetzen, wenn es mal wieder was richtig Interessantes zu erzählen und zu berichten gibt. Ja, und das ist jetzt soweit und im Mittelpunkt dieser Sendung stehen Planetarien, eine ganz interessante Technologie, nicht nur unserer Zeit, sondern die eigentlich auch schon sehr viel Geschichte und Hintergrund hat und ja, ich begrüße Tim Florian Horn. Hallo.
Hallo.
Willkommen bei CRE.
Herzlichen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja, gern geschehen. Ja, Planetarien, es ist dein Thema, kann man so sagen.
Ja, das ist sehr gut mein Thema, sogar mittlerweile, seitdem ich zwölf bin, darf man sogar sagen. Zwölf, irgendwann war ich mal als Schüler im Planetarium, hab Feuer gefangen, dass ich da unbedingt meine Freizeit verbringen wollte, denn in Kiel, wo ich herkomme, gab es einen Verein, der das Planetarium betrieben hat und da bin ich hingeblieben, bis heute.
Was hat dich dazu gebracht, da hinzugehen?
Das Interesse an Astronomie und Raumfahrt, ich habe alle Bücher verschlungen, die Was ist was Bücher und was es so an Fernsehsendungen gab, aber irgendwann hat das nicht gereicht. Ich wollte einmal selber beobachten mit dem Teleskop, das ich dann irgendwann mal geschenkt bekommen hab und hab irgendeinen Rahmen gesucht, wo ich mich mit Leuten austauschen konnte über das Thema. Und das war im Planetarium möglich, weil es ein Verein war, weil es junge Leute waren, die da ihre Zeit verbracht haben und wir... Junge Leute.
Man würde ja jetzt eher ältere Hasen vermuten.
Manchmal ist das auch immer noch so der Fall. Aber da war es gerade so, oder hier in Berlin gibt es auch Vereine, wo es Jugendgruppen gab. Und wir durften am Sternprojektor rum programmieren, eigene Veranstaltungen produzieren, Karten verkaufen. Das war so wirklich eine schöne Zeit. Wo andere vielleicht in einen Fußballverein gingen, bin ich in einem Planetarium hängen geblieben. Und das war für meinen Berufswunsch eigentlich entscheidend. Denn in diesem Planetarium, wenn man da drin saß, gerade wenn man so zwölf ist oder 14, dann stellt man sich ja die großen Fragen. Was hat es mit dem Leben so alles so auf sich? Wo kommt man her? Wo findet man seinen eigenen Platz? Und die Astronomie, die Beschäftigung mit dem Kosmos, war für mich persönlich da ganz spannend, einfach zu merken, Mensch, das ist ein riesiges Universum. Es ist zwar eine kleine Erde, auf der wir sitzen, aber alles, was ich irgendwie mache, worum ich mich kümmere, hat einen Effekt auf andere Menschen. Ich gehöre zu einem sozialen Gefüge und ich kann was leisten. Ich habe irgendwie einen Einfluss darauf, was hier so passiert.
Wann ist dir das erste Mal klar geworden, wie das ist mit der Erde und dem Universum? Kann man das dann aus den Was ist was-Büchern?
Die waren leider nicht so gut, wie man sich das so wünscht. Aber dieses im Planetarium sitzen, den Sternenhimmel sehen und zum ersten Mal so auf diesem schwarzen Hintergrund des Himmels zu merken, Mensch, das ist ganz schön weit alles weg und wir sind auf so einem kleinen Planeten da unten drauf. Das war im Planetarium für mich eine große Erkenntnis.
Wie ist man da so aufgenommen worden?
Mit dem Verein oder wenn es zu Ende ist?
Bisher irgendwie aufgelaufen, irgendwann mal, am ersten Tag, wird man da gleich mit offenen Armen empfangen.
Ja, das war ja im Grunde ein ganzer Freak-Schuppen, müsste man so böse vielleicht sagen. Weil eine Astro AG konnte man als, ja in der Freizeit machen, Jugendgruppe, das war wirklich, ich glaube, in dieser Landschaft der Planetarien einmalig. Bei den Großplanetarien, bei den Häusern, die alle so 20 Meter Durchmesser haben, 300 Sitzplätze, ist das ja was anderes. Die sind alle in Deutschland mit festangestellten Mitarbeitern und einer Crew aus 10, 20 Leuten. Da gibt es nur wenige Beispiele, wo es auch solche Jugendgruppen gibt, wo es solche Möglichkeiten gibt, sich als autonomal da einzubringen. Zum Beispiel hier in Berlin gibt es in der Wilhelm-Förster-Sternwarte oder an der Archenholz-Sternwarte Jugendgruppen, Astro AGs, an denen man sich ähnlich verwirklichen kann.
Und was hast du dann da gemacht? Was ist da schon leicht angedeutet? Wie groß war denn dieses Planetarium?
6,35 Meter. An der Hochschule ist das der Campus umgezogen worden und ein bisschen größer geworden. Aber wir haben da ja alles gemacht, von irgendwelchen Informationsständen zum Kieler Umschlag, ein Volksfest zu stehen und über das Planetarium zu informieren. Wir haben Karten verkauft, Flyer gedruckt, was halt so anfällt, um so ein kleines Theater, ein kleines Planetarium zu betreiben. Nachher ist es dann, weil es so gut lief, professionalisiert worden, könnte man so beschreiben. Man hat gemerkt, dass man ja nicht nur in so einem Planetarium Astronomie zeigen kann, sondern heutzutage sogar mit digitaler Technik 360-Grad-Video zeigen kann. Und dann ist dort das Planetarium Teil geworden der Studiengangs-Multimedia-Produktion. Man hat dann jungen Leuten beigebracht, in 360 Grad zu produzieren. Weil, wenn man sich das Medien historisch anguckt oder medienpäagogisch, dann versucht man immer, die Immersion herzustellen. Dass man im Bild, im Gezeigten oder wie hier im Gehörten einzugehen und in diesen Kosmos einzutauchen. Und das kann man im Planetarium perfekt. Das konnte man mit Sternen, das kann man aber auch mit Videoprojektionen so machen, dass man dann nicht nur zum Orion-Nebel fliegt, sondern in die menschliche Blutbahn oder die Fotosynthese so erklärt, dass man das sich auch wirklich vorstellen kann.
Sowas habt ihr dann da auch gemacht?
Und das war dann nachher ein Teil dieses Studiengangs. Und ich hatte Glück, dass ich da auch noch in die Studiengangs reingekommen bin, dass wir gleichzeitig dieses erste digitale Planetarium Europas gebaut haben. Oder erste digitale Zentraleuropas gebaut haben in Kiel 2002, 2003 war das. Und dann das auch völlig neu ausprobiert haben. Wir haben mal mit Fury in the Slaughterhouse ein Album visualisiert.
Diese handowasche Band, ne?
Ich glaube, die gibt es gar nicht mehr. Ich weiß es gar nicht. Aber da waren wir 30 Studenten, die das dann in 360 Grad umgesetzt haben. So als erstes Mal. Wir haben ganz viele erste Sachen ausprobieren dürfen.
Stimmt, die gibt es nicht mehr. 2008 haben sie ihre Tätigkeit eingestellt.
Aber die gibt es noch alle, ne?
Neugründung 2011. Die kommen ja dann immer alle wieder zusammen.
Weil sie merken, es geht dann doch nicht.
Die Band muss wieder zusammenkommen.
Wir haben doch schon immer zusammengehört.
Das ist natürlich jetzt ein interessanter Umbruch, dieser Wechsel zu einem digitalen System. Und ich denke, wenn man sich das heute so klarmacht, ist das irgendwie sehr naheliegend, dass man eigentlich alles mit Pixeln beschießen möchte. Aber so fing es ja nicht an. Also am Anfang gab es ja diese Möglichkeiten natürlich nicht. Wann gab es denn das erste Planetarium überhaupt? Also seit wann, wie weit muss man denn da zurückgehen in der Geschichte? Wann hat denn das erste Mal jemand angefangen, das Weltall zu visualisieren?
Die Visualisierung des Weltalls ist ja schon älter. Wenn man sich anguckt in Australien, gibt es auf verschiedenen Felsen Zeichnungen vom Sternenhimmel. Es gibt immer die Idee, wie muss man den Himmel darstellen. Was man aber irgendwann brauchte, war fürs Deutsche Museum ein Saal, der Planetarium genannt werden sollte. Das Deutsche Museum in München wurde errichtet und die Idee war, in einer technikverliebten Zeit einen Ort zu finden, an dem man die Bewegung der Planeten präsentieren kann. Bis dahin waren Planetarien Orte oder kleine Modelle eigentlich, wo die Sonne in der Mitte war und man über eine Kurbel die Planeten um die Sonne herumgekurbelt hat.
Von welcher technikverliebten Zeit reden wir jetzt gerade?
18. bis 19. Jahrhundert. Und da, an diesem Punkt, hat man dann irgendwann, als man das Deutsche Museum bauen wollte, versucht ein größeres Planetarium zu bauen. Es gab eine Möglichkeit, dass man auch wieder so ein riesiges Gestänge baut, ein riesig großer Raum, wo man dann vielleicht auf so einer Art Käfig sitzt für die Erde und dann einfach rumfliegt, um die Sonne, um die Bewegung der Planeten nachzuvollziehen. Die Firma Zeiss wurde aber so ein bisschen davon überredet, dazu überredet, sich dieses mal genauer anzugucken und zu überlegen, ob man da nicht noch was anderes machen könnte. Der Konstruktor Bauersfeld hatte so um 1915 die Idee, ein Projektionsplanetarium zu machen. Also eine Halbkugel zu haben, gemauert, Beton, was auch immer, und ein Projektionsapparat in die Mitte zu stellen, sodass man die Sterne und die Planeten an die Kuppel projizieren kann. Man könnte ja auch überlegen, ob man eine Kuppel nimmt und da Löcher reinmacht. Ist aber alles nicht beweglich. Auch die Planetenpositionen stimmen dann natürlich irgendwie nicht. Da muss man die da ran kleben oder was auch immer. Und dieser Herr Walter Bauersfeld hatte die Idee und die Umsetzungsmöglichkeiten, ein Projektionsplanetarium herzustellen. 1923 hat man das dann alles fertiggestellt. Auf dem Werksdach von Jena, von Carl Zeiss Jena, hat man eine Testkuppel aufgestellt und es kamen gleich tausende Leute, um sich das anzugucken. Man sprach vom Wunder von Jena. Alle, die da reinkamen, waren völlig ergriffen, auch emotional ergriffen, von dieser Projektionsgüte der Sternen. Mitten am Tag konnte man in einen Raum gehen, in die Sterne gucken und hat die erklärt bekommen. Dann war natürlich das Deutsche Museum ein bisschen beleidigt. Die haben das Ding bestellt, die haben Zeiss sogar überredet, das überhaupt nur zu erfinden. Es gibt auch lustige Briefwechsel, wo der Kunde quasi mit dem Auftrag droht. Und von 1925 im Oktober kriegte man dann den Projekt zu endlich nach München, konnte ihn in der Fest einbauen und in dieses neue, schöne, deutsche Museum reinbringen.
Also derselbe Projektor, den der Bauersfeld erst mal in Jena gebaut hat?
Nochmal ein bisschen modifiziert und der kam dann endlich zum Kunden 1925. Mittlerweile hatten aber viele Städte, viele Stadtherren das wohl schon gesehen in Jena, dann später auch in München, am eigentlichen Standort, und wollten auch sowas haben, sodass es dann in Hamburg, in Barmen, das ist heute Wuppertal, Düsseldorf und Co., Projekte gab, solche Planetarien zu bauen, eben nicht zur Volksbelustigung, sondern wirklich zur leeren Sternenhimmel, Navigation, unser Platz im Kosmos. Und recht früh hat man schon gemerkt, dass die einzelne reine Sternprojektion nicht ausreicht, sondern man Diaprojektionen, Bilderprojektionen hinzufügen muss, um ja noch ein bisschen weiter zu erklären. Wie sehen die Planeten aus? Oder die Nebel, die man am Himmel hat, die Sternentstellungsgebiete, Galaxien, wie muss man sich die vorstellen? Da hat man schon früh angefangen, zusätzliche Medien hinzuzufügen.
So richtig viel wusste man ja im Vergleich zu heute noch gar nicht über das Weltall. Okay, 23, da war Einstein schon durch, Gravitationen. Man hatte schon mit Kepler, schon lange Zeit vorher die Planetenbahnen etc. herausgefunden. Das Prinzip des elliptischen Umkreisens der Sonne, das war ja im Prinzip schon alles da. Aber das dann alles zu berechnen mit einem Projektor, wie hat das denn funktioniert? Also es musste ja quasi in diesem Projektor quasi so ein Miniatur-Abbild dieser Planeten-Technik mit drin sein. Also wie muss man sich dieses Gerät vorstellen, was da gebaut wurde?
Das einfachste an diesem Gerät sind erstmal die Sterne überhaupt. Da würde ich sagen, da kann man nicht viel falsch machen. Heutzutage macht man natürlich Bilder vom Himmel und sorgt dann dafür, dass man das Abbild gut hinbekommt. Wie macht man das? Man teilt den Himmel in verschiedene große Felder auf, hat kleine Metallplatten und in die werden Löcher reingebohrt. Je größer das Loch ist, desto mehr Licht kommt durch, desto heller ist der Stern im Himmel wie eine Diaprojektion. Man hat eine helle Glühbirne in der Mitte und außen diese Metallfolie oder Metallplatte und noch ein bisschen was, um das Bild zu fokussieren, und hat dann den Stern an der Kuppel. Bei den Planeten in der Tat ist es anstrengender, weil man die ja in die richtige Position fahren muss. Man muss im Grunde die Geometrie des Sonnensystems nachbilden über Gestänge und Getriebe.
Das heißt, die Sternewerte wurden einfach als fix angenommen? Die sind sie ja nicht, aber man spricht ja auch von Fix-Sternen, weil sie sich eigentlich so wenig bewegen, dass sie so aussehen, als wären sie schon immer an derselben Stelle gewesen.
Genau, man kann davon ausgehen, wenn so ein Projektor 50 Jahre über lebt, dann bewegt sich eigentlich an den Positionen nicht wirklich was. Es gibt so ein, zwei Sterne, da würde man das durchaus sehen, aber die hat man dann erstmal als fix angenommen, weil man ja bei Technik immer davon ausgeht, dass das nicht ewig hält. Würde ich jetzt mal so böse sagen. Und bei den Planeten, bei den ersten Projektoren, konnte man von 1950 bis 2000, oder von 1900 bis 2000, die Planeten hin und her fahren. Wir haben das immer noch so bei analogen Projektoren. Wir haben zum Beispiel in den Archenholz-Sternenwarte noch einen analogen Projektor. Da ist es so, dass wenn jemand kommt und sein Geburtsdatum wissen möchte, oder seinen Geburtssternhimmel sehen möchte, dann müssen wir auch mal 20 Minuten im Projektor die Gegend fahren, damit eben die Gestänge und Getriebe die Position der Planeten richtig hinbekommen.
Das heißt, die eigentliche Herausforderung sind die Planetenbahnen, weil das das Veränderlichste im Sternenbild von der Erde ausgesehen ist.
Weil die Herausforderung ist, dass wir mit der Erde ja nicht im Zentrum sind, sondern an dritter Stelle, dritter Planet und daher die Planeten manchmal, die äußeren Planeten von uns ausgesehen, auch rückwärts laufen vor dem Hintergrund der Sterne. Das war ja im Grunde auch das Problem, dass man in der Astronomie jahrhundertelang hatte, als man noch dachte, die Erde sei im Zentrum. Dass man es überhaupt nicht richtig hinbekommen hat, zu verstehen, wie das da oder wie die Himmelsmechanik eigentlich aussieht. Und erst die Freiheit zu sagen, na ja, wir kreisen ja auch um die Sonne. Das hat es deutlich vereinfacht.
Da kriegt eigentlich der Begriff Himmelsmechanik erst mal so richtig seine Bedeutung. Weil genau das ist ja eigentlich so ein Planetariumsprojekt. Das ist eine Mechanik.
Das ist eine Mechanik, um die man sich gut kümmern muss.
Und das hat alles dieser Bauersfeld gemacht.
Und das Team von Zeiss.
Und das heißt, die haben auch diese notwendige Expertise aufgebaut, diese ganzen Planetenbahnen mechanisch nachfahren zu können.
Genau.
Und das haben die alles selber gemacht?
Das haben die in der Umsetzung auf diesen Projektor alles selber gemacht. Mit Astronomen zusammen. Zeiss weiß und wusste, wie man astronomische Berechnungen anstellt. Es ist aber mittlerweile nicht die einzige Firma, die das kann. Heutzutage gibt es die Firma Spitz in den USA oder Goto in Japan, die ebenfalls solche Projektoren herstellen. Das ist für Deutschland interessanterweise ein großer oder ist es immer noch ein Exportschlager aus Jena, die Projektoren in alle Welt zu verkaufen.
Das heißt, diese mechanischen Projektoren werden auch nach wie vor gebaut und werden auch nach wie vor installiert? Wo ist die Zeit jetzt ein bisschen vorbei?
Nein, weil trotz digitaler Projektion kriegt man die optische Güte eines Sternenhimmels noch nicht mit Video-Beamern hin. Deswegen braucht man immer noch so ein Projektor, so ein Ungetüm in der Mitte. Die sehen jetzt ein bisschen anders aus, weil die Planeten heute nicht mehr über Getriebe an die Position gebracht werden, sondern über ein Computerprogramm und dann einen Schrittmotor, der dann sagt, im Jahr 2000, 3. März, da war der Planet da. Dann kann man innerhalb von Sekunden auf ein anderes Datum umstellen und muss nicht mehr ewig kurbeln.
Ja, wie weit konnte man denn da zurückkurbeln?
Kommt auf den Projektor an. Ich meine, dass wir, dass im Zeitraum von 100 Jahren, irgendwann wird es halt doch ein bisschen ungenauer.
Aber im Prinzip ist ja in dieser Mechanik, die Algorithmik der Bahnen kodiert.
Genau.
Das ist ja eigentlich das Fette da.
Und da muss man ein bisschen tricksen, damit es dann für die 100 Jahre gut hinkommt. Aber irgendwann wird es zu ungenau, weil man, es ist ja ein Endkörperproblem, unser Sonnensystem, da ziehen sich alle Planeten ja gegenseitig an. Und irgendwann wird es dann, wenn man nur von reiner Sicht ausgeht, etwas ungenau.
Weiß man denn, wie genau der ursprüngliche Projektor war?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Das lässt sich ja mittlerweile dann doch ganz gut nachberechnen, nehme ich mal an.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da die Möglichkeit gab, oder ob das jemand aufgeschrieben hat, weil der Projektor war ja zig Jahre im Deutschen Museum in Betrieb. Der steht jetzt auf dem Flur oder in so einem Treppenhaus, von Plexiglas umhüllt. Mit digitaler Projektion ist es natürlich einfacher. Da kann man dann immer wieder nachregeln. Zum Beispiel das Deutsche Museum hat jetzt, ich glaube nächste oder übernächste Woche, die große Wiedereröffnung des ersten Planetariums dort. Das ist natürlich ein sehr historischer Ort und die haben jetzt auch, wie der Technik von Zeiss, auch durch eine digitale Projektion ergänzt. Im alten Raum, den sie dann zeitgenössisch angepasst haben. Ich glaube, das ist ein sehr schöner Bestandteil von diesem Museum. Da freue ich mich schon sehr darauf zu sehen, was die da rausgemacht haben.
Dieses Jahr ist es?
Dieses Jahr, ich glaube in zwei Wochen ist die Wiedereröffnung. Wir haben ja dieses Jahr auch das internationale Jahr des Lichts. Und da wird das Deutsche Museum auch einiges zu machen.
Ach, der richtige Zeitpunkt, mal hier das Datum zu nennen. 12. Februar 2015 ist der Tag, an dem wir uns unterhalten. Ich muss das immer sagen, weil Podcasts werden ja noch in 500 Jahren gehört. Und da muss man dann entsprechend zurückspulen können. Mich interessiert nochmal diese Mechanik, weil das ist ja irgendwie so ein komischer Knochen, der da irgendwie in der Mitte herausragt. Also wie viele Sterne waren in... Also oben ist sozusagen diese Kugel, und die bildet quasi das komplette Sternenbild, was die Erde umgibt, ab. Also einschließlich Nord- und Südhalbkugel.
Genau, also dieser lange Knochen in der Mitte sind die Planeten, die Gestänge, die sichtbaren Planeten, Sonne und Mond. Also man hat Sonne, Mond, Merkur, Venus, Mars, Jupiter, Saturn. Zu dunkel. Also man bräuchte für Uranus, Neptun und Pluto schon ein Teleskop. Und dieser Projektor hat die Aufgabe, den für das Auge Sichtbare darzustellen.
Das heißt, die wurden gar nicht modelliert?
Die wurden schonmal weggelassen, um das ein bisschen zu vereinfachen. Man könnte jetzt argumentieren, Uranus könnte man unter Umständen doch schon mit bloßem Auge sehen. Also da wird es ein bisschen schwammig. Aber diese Kugeln, die außen an diesem Knochen hängen. Die eine Kugel zeigt alle Sterne, die Kinder vom Nordpol auszusehen werden. Und die andere, die man vom Südpol aus sehen würde. Da wir uns ja irgendwo dazwischen befinden, steht so ein Projektor, wenn man in die Planetarien kommt, meistens schon ein bisschen schräg. Und die Schräge bedeutet eben, wo man sich auf der Erde befindet.
Das heißt, wenn man quer steht, ist man auf dem Ekator?
Genau. Heute baut man die Dinge aber auch wieder anders. Dadurch, dass man die Planeten digital machen kann, stehen die auf Projektoren irgendwo anders im Raum. Meistens direkt davor, irgendwie so eine Batteriebank sieht es aus. Und diese beiden Kugeln des Sternprojektors sind zusammengeklatscht, dass der Projektor dann aussieht wie ein Tee-Ei.
Und wie viele Sterne waren da drin?
9.300.
9.300?
Plus Milchstraße.
Und sind das irgendwie auch alle, die man sehen kann?
Die man unter allerbesten Voraussetzungen sehen könnte. Das ist so das nächste. In Berlin sieht man vielleicht 100, 200.
Wo kann man die sehen? Es gibt auch so, irgendwo in Brandenburg gibt es doch so ein...
Gülpe, Sternpark Gülpe oder Westhafenland, da so ein bisschen rausfahren, Stunde, eineinhalb, westlich von Berlin. Das ist für Deutschland eine der zwei, drei guten Standorte.
Das ist so ein zertifizierter Standort, wo es auch generell dunkel zu sein hat. Ich glaube, da gibt es richtig Auflagen auch für die Gemeinde, dass da nicht so viel Licht produziert werden darf, damit man da ein gutes Sternenbild sehen kann.
Denn egal, wo wir Menschen uns bewegen, wir haben immer sehr viel Licht an, ob das nur die Handys sind, ob das die Straßenlaternen sind, das Licht aus den Häusern. Und in dem Bereich, in diesem Sternenpark oder in der Gemeinde, da wird wirklich drauf geachtet, weil auch die internationale Organisation für den dunklen Himmel, International Dark Sky Association, für alles gibt es immer eine Vereinigung und eine Gruppe. Die kümmert sich darum, Empfehlungen auszusprechen, was man machen muss, damit man den Himmel noch sehen kann. Weil das hat ja nicht nur Auswirkungen auf, wir gucken die Sterne, das ist ja vielleicht ein Add-on, sondern es hat auch biologische Faktoren oder medizinische Faktoren. Also wenn überall Licht an ist, dann ist es so, dass die Menschen schlechter schlafen, eher krank werden oder die Flora und Fauna sich nicht mehr so richtig an die Jahreszeiten hält. Lichtverschmutzung. Und da in dem weitesten Sinne ist es, glaube ich, auch ein Energiefaktor. Damit kann man Geld sparen, wenn man mehr Licht ausmacht. Was ja für öffentliche Verwaltung heutzutage auch spannend ist. Und jetzt hier in Berlin wird auch gerade wieder diskutiert, die alten Gaslampen durch LED-Lampen auszutauschen. Das ist ja erst mal besser, aber dann ist es ein anderes Licht, das die Leute durch den höheren Blauanteil nicht schlafen lässt.
Ja, wach macht. Wobei ja. Also wie muss man sich denn die Verschleierung des Himmels zu vorstellen? Wenn wir 9.300 Sterne theoretisch sehen könnten und 100 kommen jetzt in Berlin so durch, wie viel würden dann in Gülpe zu sehen sein, wenn es mal wirklich richtig dunkel ist?
9.300. Das ist ein Ort, wo man wirklich alles noch sehen kann.
Really?
Das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, da mal hinzufahren. Die bieten Vorträge an und ich glaube auch Führung und all dergleichen.
Ich nehme an, du warst da mal.
Ich war da noch nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Ach wirklich? Das wär doch mal was, oder?
Jetzt haben auch mal meine Kinder langsam das Alte erreicht, wo ich dann mit den Abends mal solche Touren machen kann wieder.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele solche Dark Sky Places es wirklich gibt. Es sind so viele, glaube ich nicht, zumindest nicht in Europa.
Europa ist in der Tat sehr, sehr dünn. Ich durfte einmal in Australien bei so einer Rundreise, sind wir einfach mal ins Outback rausgefahren, haben uns zwei, drei Teleskope mitgenommen. Und den Himmel werde ich in der Tat nie vergessen. Das war wirklich genial. Also ich dachte ja so mit zig Jahren Erfahrung im Planetarium und Astronomie und selber beobachten und all dergleichen, wüsste ich, wie ein Sternhimmel aussehen muss. Aber das war nochmal eine ganze Ecke deutlich schöner. Also die Milchstraße so hell, die Sterne so hell, dass die Schatten werfen. Der Himmel ist eben nicht schwarz, der Hintergrund, sondern grau von den ganzen Sternen, die dann da zwar mit dem Auge nicht nur auflösbar sind, aber da irgendwie im Hintergrund noch sind. Das werde ich meinen Lebtag nicht vergessen, wie wir da alle raus sind.
Ich war mal in Afrika, aber auch ganz ordentlich dunkel. Kann mich allerdings gar nicht mehr so richtig dran erinnern, welchen Eindruck ich so vom Himmel hatte. Da war ich noch von ein paar anderen Sachen mehr gefangen, aber das hat sich schon deutlich. Das ist glaube ich überhaupt so eine der Erkenntnisse, wenn man so den Himmel mal wirklich ein bisschen nackter beobachtet, wie unfassbar präsent diese Milchstraße ist. Die ja letzten Endes nichts anderes ist als unsere Galaxie im Querschnitt. Die Ebene aller Sterne unserer Heimatgalaxie. Ich glaube, man taxiert das derzeit auf so 100 Milliarden Sterne. 300.
Also diese Erkenntnis aber zu sagen, wir sind ja in der Milchstraße drin, und das ist einfach die Ebene, hat uns auch ein paar 100 Jahre gekostet.
Gibt es gerade ein paar schöne Missionen, die da Gaia, glaube ich, ist unterwegs und zählt?
100 Millionen Sterne, mal eben schnell. Also drei, vier Jahre dauert es noch, bis wir da einen guten Datenkatalog haben. Aber diese Vermessung der Welt, die Vermessung des Universums hat uns ja schon ganz gut vorangebracht. Und das Planetarium wäre dann ja leider ein bisschen limitiert, das zu zeigen, wenn man nur diesen Sternprojektor hätte. Dann haben wir die 9300, an denen ändert sich ja nicht so viel. Die Planeten, mein Gott, wir haben jetzt bis, wir haben überall schon mal Sonden hingeschickt, bei Merkur, die Messenger, Venus, Venus Express, Venera, sonst was. Mars, ganz viele, Jupiter, Saturn. Bei Pluto fliegt demnächst was vorbei. Also das kennen wir eigentlich ganz gut. Der nächste Schritt für so ein Planetarium, wenn es wirklich das Universum darstellen will, ist dann in die zusätzliche Projektion zu gehen. Also hier wieder die digitale Projektion, was ich vorhin schon mal erzählt hatte.
Also vor allem mehr Sterne zu zeigen, als man von der Erde aus sehen kann.
Und in anderen Wellenlängenbereichen. Das, was das Planetarium in der Grundausstattung zeigt, ist ja das, was unsere Augen sehen könnten. Also auch in dem Wellenlängenbereich. Da gibt es Infrarotastronomie, Gammastrahlen, Röntgenstrahlen. Das ist ein ganz anderer Kosmos, der sich da auftut. Und das alles in Einklang zu bringen, soll dann die digitale Projektion machen. Dann stellt man anstatt, also man stellt ja vielleicht weiterhin so einen Sternprojektor in die Mitte, aber außen herum digitale Projektoren, Beamer. Das Bild überlappt, da macht man vernünftige Überblendungen und setzt dahinter einen Computercluster, der entweder Video einfach abspielen kann, 360-Grad-Video zeigen kann, oder man macht es so, dass es eine Datenbank dahinter gibt und ein Real-Time-Engine, ein Echtzeit-Engine, die einen ermöglicht, durchs All zu fliegen. Also die Sternposition Gaia, da wird der kleine Datenkatalog für Planetarien 70 GB groß sein. Oder die Position der Galaxien, all das kann man in diese Engine, in diesen virtuellen Kosmos einpflegen und live berechnen.
Das sind auch verfügbare Daten dann?
Das sind verfügbare Daten. Es gab in den USA ein Projekt, das hieß Digital Universe, auch an einem großen Autorkundemuseum. Und dort hat man angefangen, alle verfügbaren astronomischen Daten zusammenzufügen in eben eine solche Datenbank, die ineinander verschachtelt den Flug durchs All ermöglicht. Und das Spannende an so einem solchen Projekt ist, dass manchmal unerwartete Dinge passieren. Es sollte eigentlich eine Datenbank werden, die sich rein um astronomische Daten kümmert und rein nach außen blickt von der Erde aus. Dann haben die in New York, aber im Hayden Planetarium im Jahr 2000 angefangen, auch Touren anzubieten, Tour durchs Universum. Und immer wieder fliegt man raus bis in den Rand des uns bekannten Universums und zurück. Sie hatten aber die Erde vergessen, beim ganzen Modellieren. Und das war der entscheidende, der Wink. Bei all dem, was wir machen, wir gucken gern nach draußen, suchen unseren Platz im Kosmos, dürfen wir die Erde nicht vergessen. Wir kommen immer wieder zu unserer Heimat zurück und merken dann ja vielleicht erst ihren entscheidenden Wert.
Heidenplanetarium, da kommt auch dieser Neil deGrasse Tyson her. Oder ist er Chef von dem Planetarium? Oder war er Chef?
Ist er immer noch.
Ist er immer noch. Das heißt, ich vermute mal, das spielt eine besondere Rolle, das Heidenplanetarium.
Weltweit spielt das Heidenplanetarium eine sehr große Rolle, weil von dort sehr gute astronomische Veranstaltungen kommen. Der neuste Produktion heißt Dark Universe, kümmert sich um dunkle Energie, dunkle Manterie und wird sicherlich auch ein Programm, das wir hier im neuen Zeiss-Großplanetarium spielen wollen. Aber nicht unkommentiert, denn in den USA, wenn die Teilen ein Science Center sind, bei den Planetarien ist es oft so, dass deren Programme nur 25 Minuten lang sind. Das finde ich ein bisschen kurz.
Der Rest ist Werbung.
Der Rest ist Werbung, nicht unbedingt. Die müssen alle halbe Stunde da Leute reinkriegen. Wir sind hier nicht Teil eines Science Centers, sodass wir gerne ein Stunde-Programm machen wollen.
Da kommen wir gleich zu. Mich interessiert jetzt nochmal dieser Übergang vom analogen, doch recht limitierten, auf die Erde, auf die Erdperspektive limitierten und eben von der Zahl der Sterne limitierten Perspektive eines analogen, was ja im Prinzip auch so diese terrestrische Zentrität, wie sagt man, dieses geozentrische Bild im Prinzip zementiert oder zunächst einmal kein anderes ermöglicht. In Kiel habt ihr jetzt angefangen, den alten Projektor durch ein digitales System zu ersetzen, 2002, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Genau, Kiel ganz ersetzt, ja.
Was genau habt ihr da gemacht? Kannst du mal diesen Übergang von analog zu digital ein bisschen auffächern?
Ich sollte vielleicht noch dazu sagen, man hat natürlich auch vorher schon 360 Grad Bilder gehabt. Das waren aber Diaprojektoren, das waren immer statische Bilder. Und wir hatten nicht genug Geld uns beides zu kaufen nachher. Wir hatten bei der Umzug des Campus und Neubau nicht genug Geld, um einen Sternprojektor zu kaufen, einen klassischen und ein digitales System. Wir haben lange überlegt, was wir dann eigentlich machen und haben uns nachher für das digitale System entschieden, weil die Idee war, so eine Medienkuppel, ein digitales Planetarium, kann man ja nicht nur für die Astronomie benutzen, sondern man kann eigentlich allen Wissenschaften einen Forum bieten. Das Planetarium hat sich naturgemäß immer auf die Astronomie beschränkt. Wir haben hier so einen Projektor, der zeigt Sterne, also erzählen wir was über Sterne. Wenn man aber anfängt, in der Immersion Geschichten zu erzählen, mit einem gestochen scharfen Videobild, was IMAX nicht kann, was das Kino nicht kann, was auch ein Naturkundemuseum nicht kann, weil es nicht an den Ort hinfliegen kann, dann wäre es schade, wenn man das nur auf das Thema Astronomie beschränkt. So haben wir das Haus in Kiel auch nicht mehr Planetarium genannt, sondern im Mediendom, weil es eben auch Teil von Forschung und Lehre war. Im Planetarium Hamburg, das im Wasserturm, im Hamburger Stadtpark, noch traditioneller war, haben wir ebenfalls so aufgebohrt, aber uns da gesagt, also nach meiner Zeit in Kiel und einem kleinen Ausflug in die USA, war ich dann am Planetarium Hamburg, da haben wir den Namen so gelassen, weil wir einfach gesagt haben, wir werden einfach neu definieren, was Planetarium bedeutet. Früher hat man immer gedacht, ein bisschen Sterne, ein bisschen Sternbilder und dergleichen, und in Zukunft soll man auch den Teil Planet ein bisschen besser verstehen, der ja weiterführt als nur die Sterne.
Was habt ihr jetzt konkret gemacht? Also was heißt jetzt digitale Projektion? Also was nimmt man jetzt? Und wie kriegt man das vor allem auf so eine 360°, 180° Kuppel?
Durch klassische 3D-Visualisierung. Man findet Leute, die 3D-Studie Max oder Maya, Cinema 4D können. Man findet Wissenschaftler, bekommt deren Daten und setzt sich mit denen hin, um deren Vorstellungen zu visualisieren. Man kann natürlich auch ohne den Wissenschaftler loslegen und bei Wikipedia gucken, aber das hat natürlich nicht wirklich viel Wert. Das findet man ja in so manchen Wissenschaftssendungen im Fernsehen. Es geht wirklich darum, mit den Wissenschaftlern an ihren Themen und an ihren Daten zu arbeiten. Also Beobachtungsdaten oder 3D-Daten von Morionnebel. Da haben wir verschiedene Veranstaltungen produziert, zum Beispiel vom Urknall zur Erde ging ein Programm und Endliche Weiten hieß das. Oder eine Veranstaltung, eine andere über Erdbeben, die ich in San Francisco produziert habe. Da ging es dann darum, dass wir Simulationen aus einem Supercomputer benutzt haben, um zu zeigen, wie die Folgen eines Erdbebens in San Francisco aussehen würden. Man geht immer von den richtigen Daten aus und nutzt Technologien, die man aus der Filmproduktion kennt, um in die Kuppel zu kommen.
Das heißt, das technische Setup zu beschreiben, man nimmt einfach so viele Projektoren, wie man benötigt, um die ganze Kuppel anzustrahlen. Das ist eine Batterie von Projektoren. Wie viele kommen da zum Einsatz?
Sechs oder zehn, je nachdem, wie viel Auflösung es ist.
Und damals hattet ihr noch nicht so viele Auflösungen an?
3600 x 3600 Pixel. Das war schon ganz gut. Das war auch lange der Standard. Wir werden hier im Zeiss-Großplanatum in Berlin knapp 8000 x 8000 Pixel einbauen. Das sind dann wahrscheinlich zehn Beamer.
Also das sind schon Spezialbeamer, die jetzt eigentlich genau...
Das sind Kino-Beamer, das sind keine jetzt, die man unbedingt bei Media Markt und Co. kriegt oder Saturn, wie dein Name ja vielleicht schon suggerieren würde, sondern man holt schon Kinosachen oder Kinoprojektoren oder welche, die eigentlich für Flugsimulatoren gebaut wurden.
Okay, also ich bin ein Teil Einsitzer.
Weil die einen vernünftigen Kontrast haben. Der Projektor muss ja auch irgendwie zigtausend Stunden laufen. Ich möchte auch nicht ewig Geld ausgeben für neue Lampen, Lampengehäuse und Wartung. Denn wenn die Dinge mir kaputt gehen, dann fehlt ein Teil im Bild in der Kuppel. Das sieht man ja sofort. Deswegen geben wir da generell schon ein bisschen mehr Geld aus. Aber ansonsten ist es kein Hexenwerk. Die Beamer, die überlappen in der Projektion. Man muss also gucken, dass man in der Software, die man da so hat, es gibt mittlerweile auch kostenlose Software von Microsoft Research, World Wide Telescope, die diese Überlappung hinkriegt. Das eine Bild blendet aus, das andere Bild blendet auf der anderen Seite ein. So eine Soft-Edge-Maske fading.
Was ja auch schwierig ist, wenn man jetzt in die Kuppel hineinprojiziert hat, hat man ja zwangsläufig auch eine Verzerrung. Eine Verzerrung der zweidimensionalen Pixelmatrix. Die kann man dann zwar dreidimensional herausrechnen. Ich vermute mal, das ist dann so der Ansatz. Das heißt, man hat so die Kuppel quasi als Software-Modell und rechnet das Bild so um, dass man eine zweidimensionale Projektion hat, die dann eben diese Bauchigkeit entsprechend nachzeichnet. Aber dann sind ja die Pixel quasi nicht direkt übereinander, würde ich mal vermuten. Oder sind die dann noch nahe genug?
Nahe genug, bzw. du sorgst dafür, dass die sich dann überlappen. Also musst du natürlich die Projektoren so stark fixieren, dass sie sich bitte nicht bewegen. Und gute Verzerrungs-Algorithmen, Verzerrungs-Software kriegt es hin, dass man es pixelgenau sogar hinbekommt. In der neuesten Variante gibt es Auto-Alignment. Da stellt man dann zwei, drei Fish-Eye-Kameras in die Kuppel und die Software kalibriert sich dann selbst. Ich glaube es ja noch nicht, aber es soll funktionieren.
Das klingt eigentlich relativ solide, finde ich. Man schickt ja quasi so ein Bild heraus und hat eine gewisse Erwartung, wie es sein müsste. Und dann muss die Software das quasi sagen, der Punkt ist aber nicht an der Stelle. Das heißt, er kalibriert sich selber visuell und ändert darüber diese Projektionsmatrix in der Software quasi neu aus. So macht man das ja auch mit Audio, auch wenn es dann noch ein bisschen anders funktioniert. Was ich meine, ist also Ausleuchtung von Studien und so. Da wird so weißes Rauschen reingegeben und dann schaut man, was über die Mikrofone wieder zurückkommt. Das ist quasi hier die visuelle Variante davon. Aber das ist jetzt so noch nicht im Einsatz.
Das ist nur noch nicht im Einsatz. Ein paar Kollegen benutzen das schon. Ich glaube aber, dass mein Techniker, den ich jetzt schon bei mir im Planetarium habe, dass seine Augen besser sind als die Kamera. Da ist schon viel Fingerspitzengefühl nachher dabei, die Projektoren gut auszurichten.
Die Auflösung ist ja dann quasi 36.000 x 36.000 Pixel für so eine komplette Wand. Also wie viel DPI kriegt man denn da erzeugt? So viel ist es ja nicht.
Die Kuppel ist ja einigermaßen weit weg. Also man sitzt im Zuschauerraum des Planetariums und die Kuppel ist, selbst wenn man letzte Reihe hinten sitzt, Minimum anderthalb Meter weg. Betrachtungsabstand ist also immer wichtig. Wenn man sich umdreht und nach hinter sich guckt, die Pixel bestimmt nochmal sieht. Aber Hauptprojektionsrichtung nach vorne, über der Bühne, das ist Augenauflösung. Also 100 Megapixel soll ja mal Augenauflösung sein. Wir sind noch drunter. Aber es hängt immer vom Betrachtungsabstand ab und natürlich vom Content, der da oben läuft.
Ja, und vor allem mehr Pixel, mehr Guth. Das heißt, umso mehr Beamer man zum Einsatz bringt, umso besser ist es.
Ja, weil dann hat man mehr Übergänge. Und sitzt dann stundenlang in der Kuppel, um das alles ordentlich zu machen.
Es sei denn, die Software macht das ganz automatisch und toll.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Aber ich bin da recht skeptisch, könnte man sagen. Also das Planetarium in Chicago hatte 20, 21 Kanäle. Und die waren ziemlich im Fluchen. Also 21 Projektoren, entsprechend so viele Übergänge. Und die waren eigentlich jeden Morgen eine Stunde, anderthalb, trotz Auto-Alignment, trotz dieser Software-Applikation in der Kuppel, um da irgendwie ein brauchbares Bild hinzukriegen.
Obwohl die fest installiert sind?
Die waren dann immer Projektoren, sind wie Menschen fürchtig.
Die dehnen sich aus und...
Temperatur, die Kuppel. Das ist... ein Kino hat es schön einfach. Ein Kino hat ein oder zwei Projektoren, eine Leinwand, da wird drauf produziert und fertig. Das ist ja hier auch wieder ein Endkörperproblem, leider. Die Kuppel bewegt sich ein bisschen. Das ist eine riesengroße Fläche, die man ausstrahlen muss. Wenn dadurch Temperatur irgendwie die Kuppellage sich um Millimeter verändert, dann hat man den Fokuspunkt schon wieder von dem Projektor ein bisschen weg. Oder wenn einem Projektor durch Temperatur irgendwie eine Linse sich verändert. Also es ist schon nicht trivial, aber auch spannend, weil die Projektion war früher der Projektor in der Mitte, mit dem man sich ewig gekümmert hat, dem man nach 20 Betriebsstunden neu ölen musste, da irgendwelche Getriebe. Und der ist schon sehr kompliziert worden, das Hauptgerät war. Und heute verlagert sich der Fokus auf die Beamer und die Rechner. Und wir haben dann nachher in dem neuen Planetarium 80 Rechner stehen, die sich um das Berechnen und Abspielen der Veranstaltung kümmern. Also technisch wird es nicht einfacher, aber es sind eher allgemeinere Anwendungen oder IT-Probleme, die wir dann haben. Also jeder, der einen Windows-Rechner hat, wir haben dann 80 Stück.
Windows?
Ja, da sind Nvidia-Grafikkarten und alles über OpenGL. Deswegen müssen wir leider Windows-Rechner benutzen. Was heißt leider? Es funktioniert ja ganz gut und ist vom Produktionsworkflow auch beherrschbar.
Noch mal zum Verständnis. Wo befinden sich denn diese Beamer? Also inwiefern, wie kann man den verhindern, dass die jetzt mitten in der Sichtachse drin stehen? Weil wenn man jetzt in so einem Planetarium drin setzt, dann sitzt man ja in der Regel so um diesen Mittelbau herum, will natürlich auch, dass möglichst wenig einem so direkt in der Linse steht. Wie tief kann man denn diese Projektion herunterziehen? Kriegt man das alles so in den Boden versenkt, dass man das irgendwie gar nicht mehr sieht?
Man könnte die in die Mitte stellen, aber dann hat man das Problem, die Mitte kann man ja bei uns in den Keller fahren, um einfach Platz zu haben. Die stehen direkt außen unter der Kuppel. Also die Kuppel beginnt bei 2,58 Meter oder so was. Eine Tür zeige ich, wie hoch ist die? 2,20 Meter. Das heißt, wir haben da so ein paar Zentimeter, wo wir die Linsen durchstechen können. Die Projektoren selbst stehen hinten im Umgang.
Die stehen sozusagen hinter der Kuppel.
Genau, so dass wir auch ein bisschen was drum bauen können, damit man die nicht so hört, die soren sonst ein bisschen laut. Und dann sieht man nur sechs oder zehn Linsen, die da so von der Seite durchstechen. Zwischen Tür und einer Wand, die dann so auf der Höhe rumgeführt wird und der Beginn der Kuppel.
Und so habt ihr das auch in Kiel gebaut?
So haben wir es auch in Kiel gebaut. Da war die Kuppel noch ein bisschen höher. So haben wir es in Hamburg gebaut. So haben wir es in San Francisco gebaut. Sodass man von der Technik gar nicht mehr so viel sieht. Außer eben der Stammprojekt in der Mitte.
Der einfach immer noch dabei sein muss.
Der noch dabei sein muss, den wir zum Beispiel in San Francisco in Kiel aber weggelassen haben. Weil wir da einen anderen Fokus gesetzt haben. Ich habe aber in San Francisco deutlich gemerkt, dass die digitale Projektion noch nicht ausreicht, um gut Astronomie und gut Sterne zeigen zu können.
Ja, aber man muss ja dann quasi für so einen Lichtpunkt, den müsste man ja dann aus wenigen Pixeln unter oben...
Aus einem. Ja, und die Sterne werden dann eckig. Oder es geht dann um sogenannten sequenziellen Kontrast. Du kannst halt dann auf ein Pixel nicht so viele Photonen pumpen. Also nicht so die Helligkeit hinkriegen, wie du es hinkriegst, wenn du einfach eine Glasfaser hast oder ein Loch in einer kleinen Metallplatte, wo das Licht durchgeht. Dadurch ist es dann auf kleiner Fläche viel viel heller und sieht eher aus wie ein Stern.
Was für Projektoren kommen denn da zum Einsatz? Also ich vermute mal 2002 dürftet ihr ja auf ganz normale LCD Projektoren gesetzt haben.
CRTs, das waren doch Röhrenbeamer.
Röhrenbeamer waren das? Ah, schick.
Ja, die waren gut schwer, würde ich sagen.
Ja, und auch sehr schwierig zu kalibrieren. Ich weiß noch, mit den Dingern, also allein erstmal die drei Röhren dann immer. Sind das überhaupt farbigere?
Ja, das waren natürlich RGB-Röhren. 9 Zoll oder ja 9 Zoll, genau. Aber die Charakteristik ist eben, die sind zwar sehr dunkel, aber der Kontrast war immer noch in Ordnung. Und der Schwarzwert war eben in Ordnung. Also kein Strom, kein Bild.
Wenn man ein LCD-Beamer zum Beispiel nimmt, dann hat man immer enorm viel mit Leuchten, weil auch der Schwarz nicht richtig schwarz ist.
Genau, und wenn man dann noch versucht, Sterne zu zeigen und immer diesen grauen Schleier, grauen Hintergrund hätte, ist das eher kontraproduktiv. Deswegen guckt man eher auf Technologien wie SXRD von Sony, die einfach einen besseren Kontrast noch haben. Oder die neue DLP-Reihe von JVC, weil sie da nochmal nachgearbeitet haben. Also im Planetarium Hamburg zum Beispiel, da stehen zwei große Beamer von Sony. Auch schön, halt nur ein Übergang. Und die schaffen trotzdem 4K x 4K, also 4096 x 4096 Pixel auf der Kuppel, weil sie diese großen Kinoprojektoren nutzen und jeder Beamer vier Videoeingänge, vier Rechner dahinter hat.
Ah, warte mal. Silicon, jetzt habe ich es. Silicon X-Tile Reflective Display, so nennen sie das. Proprietäre Variante der LCOS-Anzeigetechnik von Sony. Okay, die machen dann 4K.
Große Ungetüme werden schön warm.
X-Tile heißt Crystal. Wo es erstmal durch diesen ganzen Marketing sprecht, wo ich komme, überhaupt zu verstehen, was Sache ist. Also das heißt, die neuen, also man muss ja jetzt mal dazu sagen, was ist schon ein paar Mal angesprochen. Bisher jetzt in Berlin, um hier einem anderen Planetarium wieder auf die Beine zu helfen, was ja auch nicht ganz geschichtsfrei ist.
Genau.
Das heißt Planetarium.
Das heißt Großplanetarium Prenzlauer Allee.
Hier direkt um die Ecke der Mitebene.
Und also historisch gesehen ist Berlin ein sehr spannendes Pflaster, auch was Planetarien angeht. Es gibt eins im Westteil der Stadt und eins im Ostteil der Stadt. Beides zwei Großplanetarium, jeweils über 20 Meter und über 300 Plätze jeweils. Und es gibt auch noch die Archenholz-Sternenwarte, da gibt es auch noch ein kleines Planetarium. Und dieses Großplanetarium hat 1987 eröffnet und hatte dabei einen besonderen Sternprojektor, das Cosmorama, das erste computergesteuerte Gerät von Zeiss. Und davon gab es auch nur vier Stück, dann ist die Wende irgendwie passiert. Und es gab interessanterweise auch eine Firma Ostzeiss und eine Westzeiss-Firma, die beide Sternprojektoren hergestellt haben, auch gegeneinander gearbeitet haben und dann mit der Wiedervereinigung auch die Firma Zeiss wiedervereinigt wurde. Und dann diese wirkliche digitale Revolution auch bei der Firma Zeiss sich durchgesetzt hat.
Das heißt, das Cosmorama ist ein herkömmlicher Sternprojektor?
Aber computergesteuert.
Was hat der dann... also was... also das heißt, man hatte keine Kurbel mehr und musste nicht mehr drehen, sondern das Ding wurde durch den Computer angefahren.
Genau, wir hatten dann auch noch 69 DIA-Projektoren und alles mögliche an Special Effects. Wir konnten Programme komplett aus der Dose spielen und dann nicht selber live sprechen, sondern Schauspieler zum Beispiel haben das eingesprochen. Also man konnte vorher schon Medientechnik programmieren, sodass es immer gleiche Abläufe gibt, aber den Sternprojektor, den ersten, den man wirklich per Computer steuern konnte, auch noch wirklich genau ansteuern konnte, war dieser Kosmorama.
Und das war 87?
Das war 87. DDR, Robotron, Computertechnik. Darf man nicht vergessen. Und die Computertechnik hat, bis wir das Planetarium zugemacht haben, für die Sanierung, April 2014, funktioniert. Wir haben Updates natürlich gemacht. Das lief nachher mal ein anderes DOS, der installiert. Und ist über Timecode eingebunden in andere, auch Windows-basierte oder Mac-basierte Mediensteuerung. Aber das hat immer noch funktioniert. Manchmal mit ein bisschen Gegentreten und Wut, aber es ging.
Das heißt, das ist im Prinzip schon die zweite Generation dieser Sternprojektoren?
Ja, erste Generation von Hand alles, zweite Computergestellung. Und die dritte ist dann jetzt die Verbindung mit digitalen Systemen, die man dann Hybrid nennt.
Was habt ihr jetzt genau vor? Also, das heißt, wird auch weiterhin einen Sternprojektor geben, wenn ich das richtig ausgehört habe? Das ist aber nicht derselbe.
Das Kosmorama kommt unten ins Foyer als Ausstellungsstück. Da kommt eine kleine Ausstellung hin zu Weltbildern und astronomischer Visualisierung. Denn im Grunde ist der Sternprojektor ja die Visualisierung eines einzigen Datensatzes, nämlich Sterne von der Erde ausgesehen. Und dann kommt in die Kuppel neben einem neuen Sternprojektor, einen neuen Stühlen, eine größeren Bühne, ein digitales System, 8K mal 8K, 60 Bilder die Sekunde und ein 3D-Soundsystem.
Also 8K für die komplette Projektion.
Ja, 8K mal 8K. Das heißt, wenn man sonst von 8K spricht, ist es 8 mal 2 oder 8 mal 3,5 durch das Kinoformat. Aber wir haben hier 8000 mal 8000. Und wir wissen noch nicht genau, welches System es wird. Wir sind dann noch mitten in den Ausschreibungen. Es ist ja europaweit und keine leichte Aufgabe. Wir machen uns das auch nicht leichter, für die nächsten 10, 20 Jahre ein vernünftiges System zu finden. Denn die Technik ist ja, die Projektionstechnik ist ja nur ein kleiner Teil. Das Spannende ist ja nachher die Software, die man darauf benutzt. Denn da gibt es auch natürlich so kleine Kriege, wie zwischen PowerPoint und Keynote. Also manche Planetarien benutzen halt gerne Software A, andere Software B. Und wir wollen uns das rausgucken, womit wir am besten arbeiten können.
Aber der Sternenprojektor kommt dann wieder von Zeiss?
Könnte auch von Zeiss kommen, ja.
Ist auch noch nicht fest.
Es gibt auch andere Anbieter da draußen.
Was wird schon noch Zeiss-Großplanatarium heißen dann?
In der Tat müsste man das vielleicht dann diskutieren. Also ich bin da ganz ergebnisoffen.
Aber es gehört jetzt nicht Zeiss?
Nein, nein.
Der Name steht jetzt noch im...
Es war mal wohl so, dass nach der Wende die Firma Zeiss Räume bei uns angemietet hatte, um Sternprojektoren aus Berlin in die Welt zu verkaufen. Die hatten den grünen Salon bei uns, so heißt ein Bereich, des Bürotrags, den hatten sie angemietet. Aber es gibt bei den Zeissplanetaren, die es ja auch so überall in Deutschland gibt, zum Beispiel das Bochumer oder auch das Zeissplanetarmer Insulana, das andere in Berlin, da wird nichts von der Firma gesponsert. Das wurde immer noch so ein bisschen firmenhörig weiterverwendet.
Aber wenn jetzt der neue Sternprojektor mehr zeigen können soll als nur die 9.300 Sterne, dann muss das durch das digitale System ergänzt werden.
Also Sterne von der Erde, Planeten, alles von der Erde ausgesehen, Sternprojektor, sobald man dann losfliegt, dann hat man dann viereckige Sterne. Das wird man ja hoffentlich nicht sehen, weil es versendet sich ja immer ein bisschen. Und wir müssen dann gucken, dass wir die Limitierung des Systems umgehen.
Und wird der neue Projektor dann mit DLP funktionieren? Das finde ich auch eine der abgefahrensten Technologien überhaupt.
Dass das funktioniert, ja.
Erstmal, dass es funktioniert, wie es auch funktioniert. Ich meine, wer das nicht weiß, DLP, was heißt das nochmal? Digital Linear Projector, also es ist ja quasi so ein Spiegel, wo jeder Pixel einzeln gekippt werden kann, der quasi direkt auf dem Chip drauf liegt. Und die Software kann halt einfach so einen Port ansteuern und dann zeigt er halt entweder in die eine Richtung oder in die andere Richtung. Und damit kann man dann in Echtzeit das Licht direkt wegspiegeln. Und dadurch hat man natürlich auch einen viel besseren Kontrast, weil hier der Schwarz nicht erzeugt wird durch ein Blockieren des LCDs, sondern eben durch die Abwesenheit von Licht.
Wobei da kommt immer noch Streulicht raus aus dem. Und wenn man dann aber noch eine zusätzliche Ebene einbaut als Filter, dann kriegt man plötzlich den Kontrast so hoch, dass man das Ding auch als Projektor vorher für Flugsimulatoren nutzen kann. Also wir wissen auch noch nicht genau, welche Projektoren es werden. Also es gibt da auch einiges an Anbietern. Und da sind wir mittendrin.
Das heißt, das Projekt ist, um das nochmal zu beschreiben, aus dem alten Zeiss-Großplanatarium, was an sich ja schon technisch ziemlich weit fortgeschritten war, zumindest für die damalige Zeit, jetzt quasi mit der allerneuesten Technologie so das Maximum rauszuholen, was man irgendwie rausholen kann.
Ja, wir waren 1987 das technisch modernste Planetarium Europas. Das werden wir jetzt wieder. Nur man könnte jetzt überlegen und fragen, warum macht ihr das denn eigentlich zu? Es ist ja auch musealer Wert, diese alte Medientechnik und den alten Projektor zu zeigen. Es ist aber schon alles auseinandergefallen in den letzten Jahren. Also wir haben für den Sternenprojektor keine Ersatzteile mehr bekommen. Wir haben die Dia-Projektoren mit Mühe und Not am Leben erhalten. Und die Medientechnik, das Gesamtmedientechnische Ensemble, das war maximal kompliziert. Wenn wir von einer auf eine andere Veranstaltung umgestellt haben, dann mussten mindestens 28 Dia-Projektoren an Dia-Magazine gewechselt werden. Und es waren sieben unterschiedliche Systeme, die dann auf das neue Programm eingefahren werden mussten. Das hat so 35 bis 45 Minuten gedauert. Und diese Veranstaltung war statisch. Die zu ändern, ist ein riesiger Aufwand. Mit der digitalen Technik wird es so sein, dass, wenn etwas Neues entdeckt wird, neue Bilder von dem Kometen-Show-Jugend-auf-Gerasimenko reinkommen. Dann kann ich die morgens auf System hochladen und in der Schulveranstaltung um 10 können wir schon hinfliegen. Wenn ein neuer Komet entdeckt wird, Bahndaten rein, zehn Minuten später ist man da. Und diese Aktualität, die ist mir wichtig zu zeigen. Denn wir wollen nicht nur technisch, sondern auch inhaltlich das modernste Europa werden. Wir werden nicht so viel aus der Dose zeigen, wo man einfach auf Play drückt. Sondern wirklich dieses Alleinstellungsmerkmal nutzen. Planetarium ist aktuell. Planetarium kann der Wissenschaften neues Forum bieten. Immer wenn etwas Neues entdeckt wird, können wir es in unserem virtuellen Kosmos in der Kuppel zeigen.
Was natürlich dann auch eine ganz andere Attraktivität ausstrahlt.
Das hoffe ich. Das ist ja das Ziel, dass wir auch die Besucherzahlen verbessern und uns ja als Institution aufbauen, die für ästhetisch ansprechend und wissenschaftlich korrekte Darstellung bekannt sein wird.
Das heißt, letztlich wird es so laufen, man projiziert, man kann jetzt, lassen wir mal den Sternenprojektor mal weg. Das ist ja quasi so die Basisinformation. Wie sieht das Weltall aus, wenn wir von der Erde nach oben schauen? Und betrachtet man nur diesen digitalen Bereich. Das heißt, das Ganze greift dann auf dieses digitale Universum zurück. Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt genau der Datensatz ist, vermutlich. Sprich, man weiß, wo ist alles. Wo sind Sternen, Sterne, wo sind Galaxien, Sternenbilder im Prinzip ja auch, diese ganze Meta-Information darüber, Nebel, etc., PP, was alles rumläuft. Was ist noch drin? Sind auch die ganzen Objekte, die ganzen Raumfahrzeuge, alle Satelliten da drin enthalten?
Alle Satellitenbahnen, die bekannt sind, gibt es auf verschiedenen Internetseiten, wo man die Daten herbekommt, ISS sowieso auf jeden Fall. Die 3D-Modelle von vielen Satelliten sind da drin. Es ist aber auch der Zugriff auf eine Protein-Datenbank drin. Es ist ein Zugang drin, um Satellitenbilder zu streamen. Es gibt die Runde der Landsateliten, die die Erde 30 Jahre lang fotografiert haben. Das Archiv ist vorhanden. Auf das kann man zugreifen, um auf Veränderung des Klimawandels aus dem All zu zeigen oder aktuelle Temperaturdaten, CO2-Daten, Populationsdaten. Denn die Erde drückt immer mehr in den Fokus unserer Veranstaltung. Immer wieder zurückkommen und merken, wir müssen mehr über diesen Planeten erzählen und die Position oder die aktuelle Lage ein bisschen besser präsentieren.
Da ist ja dieser Blick von unten nach oben gar nicht mehr so dominierend.
Nee, das ist der Perspektivwechsel. Das ist im Grunde ein Perspektivwechsel, der mit der Apollo-Mission begonnen hat. Es gibt den berühmten Erdaufgang der Erde hinter dem Mond. Diese Emotionen, die sich da widerspiegeln, in diesen Bildern, ist eigentlich das, was wir versuchen, mit dem Planetarium nachzuholen. Wir haben da immer schön gesessen, auf unseren Stühlen, einen Himmel nach oben geguckt, und gedacht, Mensch, ganz schön groß. Und jetzt mit dieser Technik können wir einen Perspektivwechsel vornehmen und sagen, ja, ist alles schön groß, wir fliegen mal hin, gucken uns das an. Mensch, aber ja, es war alles wichtig und ist schon toll, aber guck mal da zurück. Da kommen wir her, da wohnen wir. Da sind alle Menschen geboren, die du jemals kennengelernt hast und die du auch jemals kennenlernen wirst. Irgendwo hin umziehen, zum Mars, zu Kepler 22b oder Gliese 581, keine Chance. Es verändert den Fokus auch unserer Arbeit und zeigt uns eigentlich auch, wo die Aufgabe liegt. Wir müssen das Planet im Planetarium ein bisschen besser beleuchten.
Das ist eigentlich ein schönes Thema. Man blickt jetzt eigentlich mehr auf die Erde. Gerade gestern Nacht ist hier eine Falcon 9-Rakete mit diesem schönen Discover-Satelliten gestartet, der sich an diesen L1-Lagrange-Punkt setzt, also den Ort, wo man zwischen Sonne und Erde um so einen Fixpunkt herum meandern kann, sodass der Satellit immer mit der Erde mitzieht und damit quasi immer auf die sonnenzugewandte Seite der Erde blickt. Und wenn ich es richtig sehe, gibt es zumindest einmal am Tag ein Bild.
Einmal am Tag ein Komplettbild der Erde.
Kein Videostream.
Es war mal ganz am Anfang im Videostream geplant, jetzt ist es leider nur ein Bild pro Tag, aber immerhin. Ein virtuelles Bild von der gesamten Erde, sodass wir jeden Tag ein Archiv eigentlich aufmachen können, um zu gucken, wie sich die Erde verändert.
Einmal am Tag heißt es ja, dass man immer nur die selbe Seite sieht. Das kann ja nicht sein.
Mal gucken, was die jetzt wirklich da gebaut haben.
Sehen wir nur die USA jetzt, oder was?
Bei der ersten Version dieses berühmten Blue-Marble-Bildes gab es ja auch nur die Ansicht mit den USA ganz groß und auch so verzerrt, dass das in Nordamerika ein bisschen größer zu sehen war.
Das ist alles Propaganda.
Wenn die Propaganda sich so ändert, dass wir alle mal genauer auf die Erde gucken, dann kann ich damit leben.
Aber können wir noch mal vielleicht so ein bisschen, ich finde das ganz interessant, diesen kulturellen Auftrag, den so ein Planetarium machen kann. Also am Anfang war es halt so dieses, man muss das überhaupt erst mal machen, man muss überhaupt erst mal diesen Blick nach außen wenden, man muss sozusagen, die Erdatmosphäre muss überwunden werden. Wir schauen in die Ferne und wir verstehen, dass da ist ein Weltall, da sind irgendwie Sterne, das sind alles Sonnen, das sind Galaxien, etc., Und ich glaube, mich nimmt das selber auch immer extrem mit, so diese unfassbare Dimension des Universums. Jetzt hat sich ja gerade wieder ein neuer Adresszusatz ergeben vor ein paar Wochen. Jetzt wissen wir ja, dass wir ja nicht nur in der Milchstraße sind und dass wir der lokalen Gruppe angehören, sondern jetzt sind wir ja sozusagen auch noch in diesem Lanier-Kea-Cluster-Verband einsortiert. Auch das wurde ja durch so eine Langzeitbeobachtung von Sternen herausgefunden. Finde ich irgendwie absolut faszinierend, wenn man sich allgemein die Dimension dieser Struktur vorstellt, was irgendwie gar nicht geht, weil das irgendwie so viele Millionen Lichtjahre sind, das kriegt man überhaupt schon gar nicht mehr so richtig gepasst. Nichtsdestotrotz ist auch das nur so ein kleiner Schiss im Gesamtding. Ich denke, das Universum als solches abzubilden, wenn man jetzt mal wirklich in die Sterne reinschaut, kann schon mal extrem dabei helfen, ein anderes Verständnis auch für den Planeten zu bekommen. Inwiefern bist du jetzt mit anderen Zwölfjährigen da in Kontakt gekommen, die, so wie du damals, auf diese neuen Möglichkeiten stoßen?
Wir haben in San Francisco an dem Science Center ein Projekt gemacht mit Jugendlichen. Das war Dienstags und Donnerstags nachmittags. Wir haben denen das digitale Planetarium an die Hand gegeben. Wir hatten nämlich noch so ein aufblasbares 6-Meter-Teil, das wir dann bei uns in die Aula gestellt haben.
Auch so ein Instant-Planetarium?
Im Grunde, ja. Das sind zwei Koffer. Da muss man ordentlich Luft reinpusten und dann steht das. Damit könnte man auch wunderbar in der Turnhalle oder wo auch immer für sich Programme machen.
Aber die stehen nur in San Francisco?
Es gibt hier in Deutschland auch irgendwie drei oder vier Leute, die mit solchen Dingern rumfahren. Universe Dimensions gibt es zum Beispiel. Die kann man mal fragen. Die kann man dann buchen für, weiß gar nicht, was sie nehmen. Aber die sind den ganzen Tag in der Schule und zeigen dann da pro Tag tausend Kindern den Sternenhimmel. Berg und Prophet, das ist ja durchaus auch eine Frage. Ob man denn immer alle zum Planetarium kriegt oder ob das Planetarium dann nicht zu den Schulen kommt.
Wenn das Universum kommt, kommt das Universum zu dir.
Das ist eigentlich der Werbespruch, genau. Der muss ich mir gleich aufschäumen.
Ja, das wäre ja mal was für einen Kongress.
Ja, das stimmt. Und man kann, naja, in diesem Projekt mit den Jugendlichen, was wir gemacht haben, wir haben denen ein bisschen Astronomie beigebracht, wir haben denen die Software beigebracht. Und dann haben wir sie einfach mal gucken lassen, was sie denn daraus machen. Und jetzt ist nämlich genau das passiert, worauf du hinaus willst, dass sie sich in der Software ein bisschen verloren haben und einfach nur nochmal rumgeflogen sind von uns, haben sich erklären lassen, was man da eigentlich genau sieht und diese Größe des Kosmos das erste Mal gespürt haben. Noch anders, als wir das so mit 12 uns angeguckt haben. Da waren wir ja schon mit den Bildern in Was ist was Büchern und mit dem Anblick vom Sternenhimmel fasziniert. Diese Generation hat die Möglichkeit, sich das auch selber zu erarbeiten, zu erfahren. Diese Software, von der ich erzählt habe, World Wide Telescope, läuft im Browser, HTML5. Kann man einfach ausprobieren, kann man sich selbst seinen Platz im Universum suchen. Das Spannende, was dann aber passiert ist, ist, dass dieses Gefühl der Lehre, dieser Größe, Gott, was ich hier mache, ist völlig egal, dass wir eine Möglichkeit gefunden haben, das zu kanalisieren, um zu sagen, nein, nein, das ist nicht egal, was ihr hier macht. Das hat alles eine Auswirkung auf Freunde, Familie, auf den Planeten, auf den Klimawandel, was auch immer. Jeder kleine Beitrag, den wir einer Gesellschaft hinzufügen, verändert das große Ganze. Und da waren die Planetarumsprogramme, die ich die letzten 20 Jahre mir so angeguckt habe, manchmal nicht so gut, dass man ziemlich verloren draußen im All war und die Zuschauer dann auch zu mir kamen und sagten, ja, ich fühle mich so klein. Das kann aber nicht Sinn und Zweck des Planetarums sein. Das Planetarum muss sagen, ja, ja, das ist ja alles groß, das ist alles weit weg, wir sind aber Teil von diesem Universum. Jedes Atom, was wir so in uns haben, Kohlenstoff, Sauerstoff, alles erst in Sternen entstanden, wir sind Sternenstaub. Wir gehören dazu, wir sind nicht entfernt davon, sondern wir sind Teil von diesem Materiekreislauf des Universums.
Und der Supernova kein Mensch.
Genau, und wenn man zum Beispiel einen Ehering trägt, der aus Gold ist, dieses Gold ist nicht in den Sternen direkt zusammengebastelt worden, sondern erst in der Supernova. Nur Supernova-Explosionen sind so schwerwiegend und so gewalttätig, dass sie so etwas wie Gold herstellen.
Beim normalen Sonne ist glaube ich bei Eisenschluss, oder?
Bei Eisenschluss, und dann fällt das in sich irgendwann zusammen. Ein innere Kern fällt in sich zusammen. Die äußeren Hüllen werden weggepustet durch Schockwellen. Und da passieren dann genau die physikalischen und chemischen Prozesse, die zu ganz schweren Elementen und schönen Elementen wie dem Gold führen.
Das heißt, diesen Blick auf die Erde zu vermitteln, das hieß du eigentlich als Hauptaufgabe?
Und den Zugang zu Wissenschaft zu schaffen. Die Wissenschaft sitzt oft doch noch in ihrem Elfenbeinturm. Und dabei sind das ganz spannende Geschichten. Ob das nur um Gentechnologie handelt oder Platten-Tektonik, Fotosynthese, wir über die Raumfahrt sprechen, wenn wir auf einem Kometen eine Raumsonde landen. Das sind alles so Themen, die eigentlich die Möglichkeit haben, junge Menschen zu begeistern. Aber wir noch über zu viele Hürden sprechen. Der Schulunterricht, der Wissenschaftsunterricht in der Schule, da gibt es Bücher, da gibt es kleine Bildchen, die begeistern jemanden. Das Planetarium kann es aber. Oder Medien, neue Medien generell, wenn Schülerinnen und Schüler sich selbst den Zugang zu Wissenschaften mit eigenem Interesse an Sachen gehen und nicht gehemmt werden durch irgendwelche Data Policies. Weil bei der ESA müssen die Daten die ersten 400 Millionen Jahre auf dem Server irgendwo in Köln liegen, bevor sie freigegeben werden. Meine Idee ist, das was das Planetarium kann, ist eigentlich ein Datenfilter an alle wissenschaftlichen Daten und Geschichten. Wir arbeiten das auf. Wir ermöglichen aber den Zugang zu den Originaldaten, zu den Originalbeobachtungen oder Simulationen.
Das Planetarium wird so eine Art Einfallstor in die wissenschaftliche Datenwelt und ermöglicht dann am Ende auch eigene Visualisierung. Das heißt, wenn ich genug bin und nicht das interessiert, könnte ich irgendwann mal an euch herantreten und sagen, was ist dir ab hier, wie komme ich jetzt hier an die Daten ran, was kann ich damit visualisieren? Und wenn ich jetzt einen Flug vom, keine Ahnung, hier Discover-Mission, einfach mal den kompletten Start bis zu diesem Lagrange-Punkt mitfliegen möchte, dann wäre das damit möglich.
Korrekt, wir demokratisieren das Planetarium. Die Software wird auf 40 Rechnern unten im Medienlabor laufen, steht Schülerinnen und Schülern zur Verfügung. Ich kann mir aber auch vorstellen, dass wir ja Workshops machen, wie visualisiert man für die Kuppel und wirklich allen die Möglichkeit geben, diese Kuppel zu nutzen. Ich verstehe mich nicht als derjenige, der da jetzt genau vorschreibt, wann um 14 Uhr welches Programm immer laufen wird, sondern das ist ein neuer Art Medium, ein neues Wissenschaftstheater, was es so noch nicht gibt weltweit. Und wir wollen euch allen die Möglichkeit geben, in dieser Kuppel was zu machen. Wir sind die Letzten, die sagen, Mensch, das passt hier aber nicht rein. Alles was diesen Planeten angeht, ob das eine Wissenschaft ist, ob das Gesellschaft ist, hat in diesem Raum Platz.
Es findet ja nicht nur in Planetarien statt. Es gibt ja so Systeme wie dieses Kerbel-Space-Programm. Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern du dich damit schon mal auseinandergesetzt hast. Das ist ja auch so eine komplette Space-Simulation, die so ein bisschen spielerisch an die Sache herangeht. Man kann sich so quasi sein eigenes Universum programmieren. Ich habe da schon alles Mögliche mit gesehen. Es gibt da irgendwie Visualisierung der letzten Falcon 9 Returns von der Rakete etc. Alles innerhalb dieses Simulators gebaut. Man ist hier in der Lage, in so einem virtuellen Environment tatsächliche Weltraumflüge nachzubauen, alle möglichen Raketen zusammenzubauen und die dann auch damit zu visualisieren. Das wäre natürlich auch ein ganz interessanter...
Dann müssen wir nur noch die Kameras definieren und dann könnte man das direkt auf einen Cluster bringen. Also wenn die Software clusterfähig ist, dass man das auf mehrere Rechner verteilen kann, können wir es in die Kuppel bringen. Es gibt ja schon genug Sachen. Unity kann man für die Kuppel benutzen. Man kann V4 für die Kuppel benutzen. Visualisierung und ein bisschen DJ-Möglichkeiten. Kann man ja auch alles machen. Wir werden neben dem Hauptabspielsystem, das wir in der Kuppel haben, auch so einen Dev-Cluster hinstellen. HP-Maschinen oder was auch immer.
Muss man sich dann um diese Entzerrung selber Gedanken machen, dass wir dann Teil davon sind?
Das ist recht trivial sogar. Das ist einfach ein Layer, der dann hinzugefügt wird. Das machen wir dann.
Das heißt, eigentlich muss man nur ein dreidimensionales Modell liefern?
Ja, entweder schon als Video oder für die Echtzeit-Engine seiner Wahl.
Und dann wie z.B. Unity als relativ populäre 3D-Plattform, auf dem ja auch Spiele entwickelt werden, auf dem iPhone etc.
Ich bin sehr erfreut sogar darüber zu sehen, was in der Unity-Community gerade so alles passiert. Wir haben vor 5 Jahren schon Plugins geschrieben oder diese Verteilung und die Kamerasätze für Unity. Und jetzt ist es so weit, dass da sehr viele schöne Sachen entstanden sind. Jetzt muss nur noch das Planetarium fertig werden.
Wann ist denn das fertig?
Anfangs oder Frühjahr 2016. In Amtsdeutsch habe ich gelernt, heißt das Bauen im Bestand. Was auf gut Deutsch bedeutet, man macht eine Wand auf und kriegt ein paar Überraschungen.
Was für Überraschungen habt ihr da gehabt? Ich habe ein paar Fotos gesehen von dem entkernten Planetarium. Ist das noch so?
Wir sind jetzt dabei, gerade Wasserleitungen zu legen. Denn die Wasserleitungen in dem Gebäude von 1987 waren noch so Plastikrohre. Das machen wir jetzt auch nochmal. Oder das Dach zum Beispiel, das wird neu gedeckt. Das wird sogar ein grünes Dach, damit wir da auch nicht so viel Geld ausgeben müssen für Heizung und solche Geschichten.
Ach so, weil derzeit ist es ja so ein Aludach.
Und Steine sind oben drauf, also so Kies drauf. Nicht so schön. Also doch, die Kugel, das bleibt Alu. Also wir machen an dem Gebäude ja wirklich viel von die gesamte Klimaanlage, die Stromleitung neu, die ganze Netzwerktechnik natürlich in dem Gebäude. Im Planetarium selbst den Fußboden, die Stühle, die ganze Projektionskuppel, auch alles an Technik. Büroräume wird ein bisschen was gemacht. Wir haben Kino in dem Gebäude, das auch noch ertüchtigt wird.
Noch zusätzlich jetzt zu dem eigentlichen Planetarium.
Genau, und wir haben Medienlabore, eine Bibliothek. Ich suche noch jemanden, der da das Restaurant umbauen möchte. Und Shop kommt da rein, Kasse nach vorne. Also wir gehen schon ganz viel an.
Und das Planetarium auch so als Kinoprojektion zu nutzen. Ich meine, es gibt ja hier diese, wie heißt es noch gleich?
IMAX.
IMAX-Kinos, die ja im Prinzip auch so mit so einer riesigen Halbkuppel arbeiten. Ich muss zugeben, ich war einmal da drin. Das hat mich jetzt auch nicht so umgehauen. Andererseits merkt man schon, dass da so ein gewisses Potenzial ist.
Ja, aber wenn es dich nicht umgehauen hat, warum soll ich das dann machen?
Ich glaube, das war auch der Fall, wenn ich nicht so richtig umgehauen hatte in dem Moment.
Also ich habe Interstellar auf IMAX geguckt. Das ist schon atemberaubend. Aber es ist eben nicht 360 Grad. Das ist noch mal eine Ecke mehr. Die ganzen IMAX-Filme, auch Omnimax-Filme, die also für diese Kugelprojektion produziert werden, ist eben nicht die gesamte Kuppel. Von der Wahrnehmung würde man im Planetarium immer einen schwarzen Bereich sehen. Es gibt auch in den USA die Giant Screen Cinemas, die auch organisiert sind und da sonst was an Produktion haben. Das sind aber alles Narrationen, Filme, die von A nach B durchlaufen. Ich persönlich glaube, dass das Besondere an dieser Kuppel ist, dass man da einen Experten hat, mit dem man sprechen kann, der das moderiert und dass ganz viele Geschichten live passieren in der Immersion der Kuppel. Das ist ein Gruppenprozess stand. 314 Leute, die da drin sitzen, wir können in Diskurs, in Diskussion treten. Das sind die besten Veranstaltungen, wenn irgendwann jemand aufsteht und sagt, ja, aber das habe ich nicht verstanden, erklär das doch nochmal oder wie ist denn das und das? Und man wirklich sprechen kann. Filmvorführer im 360°-Kino, da kann man ja weiterhin ins IMAX gehen.
Es gibt aber auch, ich habe gerade in letzter Zeit eine Menge interessanter Quellen für so 360°-Video gesehen. Also zum Beispiel gibt es ja diese lustige Kamera, die man so hochwirft und die dann mit dem Beschleunigungssensor selber weiß, wie schnell sie gerade ist und im höchsten Punkt irgendwie auslöst und dann so ein 360°-Foto macht. Das andere, was mir natürlich einfällt, sind diese Streetview-Karren von Google, die im Prinzip auch nichts anderes machen, als durch die Stadt durchzufahren. Also man könnte so einen wunderbaren Berlin-Film machen, wo man quasi 360° einfach nur durch die Gegend fährt. Das wäre nicht verhältnismäßig einfach zu realisieren.
Also für den Unterhaltungscharakter werden wir bestimmt auch Sachen machen, aber selbst produziert. Es gibt eine Idee, die ich gerade versuche umzusetzen. Das ist in der Tat ein Musikprogramm mit Berliner Musikkünstlern, die ihre Geschichten so ein bisschen der Stadt erzählen. Also ich meine jetzt nicht irgendwie Stadtaffe oder sonst was, sondern schon neu für das Planetarium produziert. Vielleicht auch Acts, die noch gar nicht so bekannt sind, die Lust haben mit uns zusammen dieses Medium 360° auszuprobieren. Es ist ja nicht nur visuell spannend mit so einer Kamera durch die Stadt zu laufen, sondern wenn wir 360° Sound auch in diesem Raum haben, also nicht nur Surround, sondern man wirklich den Ton im gesamten Raum wahrnehmen kann und orten kann, dann müssen wir auch dafür Produktionswege finden. Also diese 360° Kameras mit GoPros, ich weiß gar nicht, was die kosten, 3500, alles zusammen. Da haben wir auch schon einige hier liegen und Sachen mit ausprobiert. Für den Unterhaltungswert werden wir es sicherlich machen, aber wir wollen nicht so viele Programme haben, die, keine Ahnung, Future is Wild oder Crash-Boom-Bang, die größten Katastrophen des Universums, die dann einfach nur durchlaufen.
Kein NTV-Programm mit Nutzen lang?
Ja, Panzer-Dokus auch nicht unbedingt.
Aber das mit der Akustik, das finde ich ganz interessant, das haben wir ja im Prinzip komplett rausgelassen. Also die Kuppel wird auch akustisch neu aufgestellt.
Wir haben wohl in der ersten Version des Planetariums mit 89 Lautsprechern schon ein 3D-Soundsystem versucht. 1987 wohlgemerkt. Das Soundsystem war schon ziemlich klasse, was wir hatten, weil wir hatten 32 Kanäle, die wir einzeln bespielen konnten. Immer noch. Das hatte mit der 3D-Sound nicht ganz so funktioniert, weil die Akustik in so einer Halbkugel sehr schwierig ist. Wir werden aber, wenn wir es jetzt alles so hinbekommen, wie wir das gerade geplant haben, ein sehr schönes 3D-Soundsystem bekommen, dass man zwar nicht den Ton in der Kuppel an jeder Position orten kann, aber auf der Kuppel, dass wir drei, vier Ebenen haben und man es wirklich lokalisieren kann, ob der Stern da vorne rechts oder hinten links explodiert.
Aber gibt es nicht bei der TU Berlin so einen Raum, wo genau das gemacht wird, diese dreidimensionale Verortung von Sound, also wo tatsächlich der komplette Raum mit so kleinen Lautsprechern ausgestattet ist und man an eine beliebige Stelle quasi einen Klang hineinprojizieren kann?
Das wäre Spatial Sound, Wellenfeld-Synthese.
Ja, genau.
Das ist aber für einen Planetarum so teuer, das kann ich mir nicht leisten.
Okay, aber cool wär's.
Cool wär's, es hat aber ein paar technische Herausforderungen, zum Beispiel wenn man den Kopf schräg stellt, dann geht dieses 3D-Sound kaputt. Es funktioniert im Moment wohl nur genau in der Ebene. Und im Planetarum ist es so, die Stühle gehen dann nach hinten, man hat auch Kinder, die irgendwie einen Meter kürzer sind.
Okay, aber man kann auf jeden Fall den Klang auch nach oben steigen lassen und nach unten steigen lassen und man kann ihn natürlich auch im Rondell herum sausen lassen.
Wenn man visuell so ein starkes Medium hat, dann vergisst man leider manchmal den Ton.
Ja, aber ist das dann nicht auch extrem abhängig von der Sitzplatzposition?
Solange man das Aufdauerkuppel orten kann, ist es glaube ich okay.
Dann geht das Hirn sozusagen mit?
Also ein Standard 5.1 surround wäre tödlich in der Kuppel, dann hat nämlich der beste Ton der Sternprojektor dann in der Mitte steht und alle anderen hören irgendwas, aber nichts, was Sinn macht.
Weil das sozusagen nur auf einem einzigen Ort das Ufer so zählt?
Genau, das Sweet Spot wäre genau das Sternprojektor. Wenn man da so wie Baron von Münchhausen drauf sitzt, hat man guten Ton. Aber sonst kommt man da nicht weit. Deswegen müssen wir viel Aufwand betreiben, auch in der Produktion. Da kann man nicht einfach einen Film abspielen auf der Kuppel oder einen fertigen Soundtrack abspielen, sondern wir müssen jede Veranstaltung auch in diesem Raum produzieren.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen auch das Besondere an dem Projekt. Es geht jetzt nicht nur darum, ein digitales Planetarium zu bauen, sondern es geht auch darum, Inhalte dafür zu produzieren, die ja im Prinzip genau dafür auch gemacht sein müssen.
Genau, wir wollen inhaltlich dieses Medium weiterentwickeln. Full Dome nennt man es. Also 360-Grad-Video sage ich eher, weil Full Dome ist sozusagen die Community, die sich gerade bildet. fulldome.org gibt es und es gibt sogar Festivals dafür. Am Planetarium in Jena gibt es jedes Jahr Mai ein Festival, wo wirklich wenig Astronomie gezeigt wird und einfach mehr auch Studenten zum Beispiel in dieser Kuppel arbeiten können. Bauhaus, Universität oder in Offenbach oder in Kiel natürlich auch dort. Dort arbeitet man viel kreativer mit dem Medium, als es vielleicht Planetarien tun.
Und das nicht nur in visueller Hinsicht, sondern auch akustisch? Auch akustisch. Das heißt im Prinzip mit fulldome.org ist dann quasi jetzt ein Content, soll ich sagen, so eine Content-Bewegung.
Genau, dann gibt es das Jena Fulldome Festival und es gibt die Imerza als Organisation, die Planetarien, die Kuppeln zu Wissenschaftstheatern weiterentwickeln wollen. Dann sind wir wieder beim Thema für jede Nische. Gibt es eine Organisation?
Imerza.
Die hat auch eine Tagung im März, das nächste Mal in Denver. Wir versuchen die natürlich auch nach Berlin zu holen. Dass die nicht nur in den USA stattfindet, sondern im Wechsel einmal in Europa.
25. Februar bis 1. Ja, da sehe ich ja auch Möglichkeiten für das Chaos-Communication-Camp. Da stand ja auch schon so ein oder andere Dom herum, der mal eine etwas intelligentere Bespielung gebrauchen könnte. Zumal ja diese ganzen Dom, es gibt ja auch zahlreiche Projekte, mit denen man sich relativ schnell so einen Dom aufbauen kann. Es gibt jetzt auch schon die ersten 3D-gedruckten Domprojekte, was ja auch ganz hilfreich ist, um so diese ganzen unterschiedlichen Gestängeabstände hinzubekommen. Und dann hätte man so quasi so ein Instant-3D-Kino, wenn man sich das von innen entsprechend auskleidet. Da muss man nur noch die Projektion hinkriegen. Da würde dann wiederum das System mit den Beamern und der automatischen Kalibration ganz gut greifen.
Oder man nimmt einen Fisheye. Also einen Fisheye-Projektionslinse. Die gibt es ja auch einigermaßen günstig.
Und dann einfach mit einem Beamer.
Und dann mit einem Beamer. Das ist in der Auflösung natürlich ziemlich berunter. Aber mit den neuen Beamern, die haben auch 2.500x irgendwas, das reicht für eine kleine Kuppel schon.
Also bis zum normalen HD oder Doppel-HD, 2K, quasi. Also man braucht jetzt noch nicht mal so einen quadratischen Industriebeamer.
Da könnte man schon ein paar Sachen ausmachen. Diese mobilen Planetarien, diese aufblasbaren Dinger, von denen ich erzählt hatte, die haben zum Beispiel nur so ein Fisheye in der Mitte mit irgendeinem JVC oder NEC-Beamer drunter. Und das funktioniert dann wunderbar. Man muss natürlich aufpassen, dass die Kinder da nicht mal drauffassen.
Wenn die da reinlaufen, ist ein bisschen heiß.
Nee, einfach nur, dass man dann einen perfekten Fingerabdruck auf der Linse hat.
Ja, Tim, ich glaube jetzt kommen wir auch so langsam ans Ende des Themas. Ich finde das ja sehr schön, weil hier bei CRE geht es ja immer um Technik, Kultur und Gesellschaft. Das ist mal wieder so ein Thema, wo das irgendwie alles zusammenkommt. Also ganz klar ist das vor allem erstmal so ein schönes technisches Spielzeug, aber es hat halt eben auch so einen kulturellen Aspekt und vor allem auch so einen wichtigen gesellschaftlichen Impact, weil gerade dieses, was du meintest, dieser Blick auf die Erde, den wieder so zurückzugewinnen, das steht jetzt irgendwie an. Ich habe ja nicht ohne Grund auch diesen Discover-Planeten-Satelliten erwähnt, weil dieser Blick zurück auf die blaue Kugel und dieses Vergegenwärtigen, das eigentlich 100 Prozent unserer Probleme auf diesem Planeten gerade schlägt, das irgendwie auf ein Bild zu bekommen und diese Selbstvergegenwärtigung, dieser doch extrem schutzbedürftigen Existenz im Universum klarer zu machen, finde ich persönlich extrem wichtig. Das ist irgendwie etwas, was eigentlich im Mittelpunkt stehen muss, weil es einfach zu wenig Verständnis dafür gibt.
Ich glaube, was eben auch fehlt, ist eine Instanz, die das sortiert. Wir haben ja alle Zugang zu allen Informationen irgendwie. Wir können bei Facebook gucken, wir können bei Twitter, beim Institut für Klimafolgenforschung lesen, was die an Pressemitteilungen haben. Wir können Spiegel online lesen, wir können überall unsere Infos holen, aber ein umfassendes Bild, eine Zusammenfassung zu liefern, einem Ort, dem wir vertrauen, das können Museen sein, das können oder soll aber in Zukunft auch das Planetarium leisten.
Dann wird das so ein kultureller Ort, wo man sich sein tägliches oder zumindest wöchentliches Update über den Zustand des Planeten abholen kann. Und wenn man sich mehr über Luftverschmutzung interessiert, dann wird man mal das Luftverschmutzungsprogramm. Und dann sieht man mal nicht nur, wie das so theoretisch an sich ist, sondern vielleicht eben auch ganz konkret, wie es ist.
Und eben aber auch den positiven Ansatz zu finden. Es ist ja nicht alles schlecht. Wir sind ja nicht jetzt in einer Abwärtsspirale, wo es keinen Ausweg gibt, sondern man merkt ja, wenn man mit Leuten über den Klimawandel spricht, dass viele einfach schnell abschalten und sagen, ich kann ja nichts machen. Aber wir müssen uns auch an den Wege und Geschichten zu finden, zu sagen, wir sind Teil des Ganzen, wir schauen aber positiv nach vorne und guck mal, das machst du jetzt und dann machen wir das zusammen und dann klappt das schon. Denn wir können als Gesellschaft Veränderungen hervorrufen. Wir müssen nur dran glauben und vernünftige Handlungsansätze zusammen definieren und finden.
Dazu können auch die Techniker was beitragen.
Vor allem, die Techniker müssen und sollen dafür was beitragen, weil sie diejenigen sind, die es sortieren für uns. Und uns den Zugang zu Daten und den Zugang zu Informationen liefern.
Schön gesagt. Das war's zu digitalen Planetarien. Und wie ich sagen würde, so ein bisschen so dem potenziellen neuen Tor zur Datenvisualisierung der Welt, wie wir es eigentlich schon lange gebraucht hätten. Unter Wasser wäre dann übrigens auch mal ganz gut, fällt mir gerade noch ein. Weil das ist ja so ein bisschen auch das totale Mysterium, wo man irgendwie überhaupt nicht weiß, was ist. Aber das Fass mache ich jetzt mal nicht auf. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war CRE. Wir kommen bald wieder. Bis bald.